it was always going to be tough for
David Moyes to follow Sir Alex Ferguson
at Manchester United few anticipated
quite how tough he inherited the English
champions nine months later they're also
rands 7th in the league and out of
Europe
hostile reception he received at Everton
on Sunday came before what may turn out
to be Moyes his last game as United
manager the grim reaper who stalked him
at Goodison Park was a bookmakers stunt
but it proved prescient Moyes his odds
on to go after this even United
loyalists struggle to make a case for
the manager well I fear for him in that
we see I think a couple of weeks ago
when these explosions happen wherever
all media outlets as you say completely
just go wild and usually ends up
inevitably in the manager get inside
have no doubts when he selected his
fellow Glaswegian over other candidates
including Jose Mourinho and ordered the
club's supporters to back him when meant
by teams here the cops stood by me all
my staff stood by me the player stood by
me your job now is to stand by a new
manager by the turn of the year many
were asking if it was beyond him
patchy in the league they were knocked
out of the FA Cup in the third round by
Swansea and the League Cup by Sunderland
left angry supporters taken to the air
to protest it proved a straw in the wind
there's been a concern amongst a number
of supporters that you know the players
haven't been putting 100% in now what
that's down to you know we don't know we
don't know whether they understand the
tactics or the plans or whether it's
something else it's all speculation
really
united's American owners the Glazer
family had been desperate for signs that
moist could be trusted with the club's
future seeing none they've decided to
act for Moyes a fine manager apparently
overwhelmed by the scale of the task
it's now a matter of when not if he is
sacked Paul Kelso Sky News